[Music]  how much money should be spent on  reducing air pollution the US  Environmental Protection Agency the EPA  try to answer this question with a  cost-benefit analysis it asked how many  lives would be saved by cleaner air and  how much was each life worth it said the  value of a life at 3.7 million dollars  except for people older than 70 whose  lives it valued at only 2.3 million  dollars flying behind the different  valuations was a utilitarian idea saving  an old person's life produces less  utility than saving a young person's  life because the young person has longer  to live and therefore more happiness  still to enjoy advocates for the elderly  did not agree they protested what they  called the senior citizen discount what  do you think with the agency right or  wrong to assign a monetary value to  human life  [Music]